[Musique]
bonsoir tous les amis bonsoir c'est pack
ouais nous avons rencontré tout plein de
cloche dans le ciel elle était très gai
et elle chantait ce point que ce couac
nous sommes tous contents l'envol aux
landes lot lot lolo et elles nous ont
remis ce bel oeuf de pâques pour petit
louis et mirabel un gros morceau va vite
leur portée ce poc et pops pas que nous
sommes tous contents le la peau comme
nous sommes tous contents lol
lolo c'est pâques
nous sommes tous contents pour elle elle
joue les eaux qu'est ce que c'est cette
1ère jeu vu les cloches a vu rémy c'est
oui
elles m'ont donné ce bel oeuf de pâques
pour mirabel est-il oui c'est gentillet
gbagbo
[Musique]
et
en
ascension mira nair qu'il est mignon
en plus il est mignon il est toujours
bien sûr il sort de son oeuf bien qu'il
a faim on peut le donner un peu de la
même envie non voyons les poussins ça ne
mange pas de l'est attendez un petit
diamant et la soif aussi sûrement
atteint la tient peu tu pousses un joli
bond un peu d'eau
[Musique]
oh
mais grosse louche on va leur mener la
campagne rythme tu crois tu veux dire
elle accompagne pousse à jouer dans
leurs petites misères que j'ai bien
l'impression que ça lui plairait assez
les poussins aime beaucoup la campagne
et qu'il aurait plein d'amis poussait et
pourra jouer avec tout plein nez et vous
lui trouverez une maman poule comme ça
il pourra faire dodo bien au chaud au
queen of et vous si maintenant vous
allez faire dodo tard il est tard tu
vois un petit poucet tu vas faire de
d'autres scènes sans fin de presse dans
ton jeu les petits ni au revoir les
enfants
allez vite vous coucher moi il faut que
je me trouve au revoir petits poussins à
demain on est petit poucet
[Musique]
bonne humeur abel
bonnet petit louis bonne nuit gentil
petit poussin vous les petits enfants
embrassez vos parents est allé sagement
vous coucher vite vite
et voilà une bonne chose de faite à la
route nounours bonne nuit
bonne nuit
[Musique]